one two three go one two three go all  right I hate it wouldn't happen hold on  to my legs Edward II I'm not got too  close to the edge it's cold man there's  no bar I know you didn't nut huh you  didn't catch at all you can't but these  guys came out and give us a hand and we  got off the shallow and hit the deep  stuff right here so the ice broke out  from underneath me you know it's one of  those things I was lucky there's someone  here to keep me hand got up on the ice  we started bringing the Machine up and  then I broke through  you got soaking white all the way up to  my bellybutton one two three oh yeah  honey girl love it more when do they go  the machines up and on the ice  the sled is up and on the ice the  caribou are okay I can attend the  machine later it's time for me right now  to go him up and change my clothes and  change my boots and go get rested up and  get back to working and making sure that  machine's good